Congress is just days away from another
government shutdown over immigration
Senator John McCain of Arizona has
released his idea of what an immigration
compromise ought to look like his bill
which was crafted with Democratic
Senator Chris Coons of Delaware would
provide amnesty for millions and
millions of illegal immigrants in return
for zero concessions no wall no when to
change migration I went to the diversity
lottery nothing it's an absurd idea that
nobody takes seriously including the
White House which just missed it out of
hand
today but it does raise the question
where are we what does the state of play
and where are we going now Noorani is
executive director of the national
immigration forum and he joins us
tonight so I think it's a pretty
baffling position that the left is in
right now so Trump has basically said I
will give you 3 million new democratic
voters and all you have to do is build a
wall which you say doesn't work anyway
so what's wrong with that I would ask
the same question because in fact the
president has turned down deals in the
over the past month that offered exactly
that but let's just take a step back I
think the president deserves credit for
putting his cards on the table Senator
McCain and Coons have done that today
and we have multiple bills in various
states of motion the president can do
something that neither President Obama
nor President Bush could do and solve
part of our nation's immigration problem
the deal is there to be had he's just
got to close it well but this stumbling
block one of a number of them but the
main one is the wall and it's confusing
to me why everyone and the people who
are against the wall are for more
illegal immigration obviously but they
argue simultaneously that the wall is
ineffective Mexico for example argues
that the wall is both an abomination and
it won't work if it won't work why are
they mad about it well see I number-one
want a secure border I want a border
that keeps us safe no but I also want no
but I just yeah let me explain I also
wanted the American taxpayer for their
money to be used the right way so the
right solution here is a combination of
technology infrastructure ports of entry
fencing and some infrastructure
strategic places let me just say that I
don't believe you I don't come close to
believe because we're talking 50 billion
dollars or 20 billion you don't you
don't believe that I care about security
and the American taxpayer not at all
why because we
just spent 50 billion on Puerto Rico
which is not even a state we spent 600
billion on the Pentagon every year and
we're not even really a war we're
talking about 20 billion on a wall and
all of a sudden people who don't care
about spending in any other part of
government are saying oh it's bad for
the deficit so you don't want the wall
cuz it might work and you know that and
I know that so you know what might wet I
think we should do here is we should do
the cart and the tucker carlson aisle
eating irani deal and that is let's
protect dreamers let's secure the border
if you want a wall let's let's take a
wall some just I mean I personally think
well whatever my views are right Trump
just offered to give millions of
so-called dreamers citizenship right not
just the legal status they can vote in
exchange for the wall and the left just
saying that wall they hate the wall
because it's a permanent solution if you
put up sensors on the border you can
take them down you hire more agents you
can reassign them the weird all is
forever you're completely in favor of a
narrow solution exactly like what you're
talking about protecting dreamers and
protecting the border no no but you're
not though you're for Border
Protection's that can be repealed
Hadrian's Wall is still there the Great
Wall of China still there
Israel's wall works lots of walls work
that's why the left so you're before a
wall like why not a billion on a little
border patrol along and that is the are
the experts on the border say you know
what we need a wall in this particular
place let's do that but so they make
decisions your area like experts making
policy is that what you're saying I'm in
favor of experts making polls I thought
the public got to make policy this is a
democracy so we've no but what gets to
make policy the public we have elections
and they voted for a wall don't they
have one because we want experts on the
border to make the right decisions and
some places are gonna say we need a wall
in other places they're gonna say wait a
second jisu you think a Border Patrol
agent or an expert yes should have more
authority than voters in a democracy
this is was that work exactly how it
works is that somebody who has had
twenty thirty years of protecting our
nation knows the best way to protect you
I have elections at all because that's
why you elect policy makers who set the
policy so that experts can implement
that but we didn't elect a policymaker
we acted to elected a reality TV star
hooray
on building a wall and people didn't
elect him because he was a reality TV
star they elected him because he wanted
to build a wall and he seemed very
literal about it and they voted for that
he won and now in Washington and we're
saying you don't get a wall you don't
know enough so maybe I'm starting to
think it's not really a real democracy
is it I think that we want our experts
to protect the American public and the
American taxpayer experts along the
border say we need a mix of
infrastructure technology and security
like ports of entry that is comfortable
with ignoring voters in why would a
voters say this is a devoted Authority
intruders and oligarchy run by people
like you the voters have spoken and they
elected Donald Trump he is our president
what did he run on he ran on securing
our border mark you ran on the wall so
then let's let's make sure we're
securing the border no let's build a
wall and anything short of that won't
that send a very clear message maybe you
disagree at all that's totally fine
you're not a trump voter they won why
wouldn't they get what they want if this
is really a democracy and if it's not it
let's just shut it down and let's just
admit it's not really democracy
it's run by four thousand people who
went to HBS and worked in McKinsey and
now we're running think tanks here let's
just be honest about it and the voters
are immaterial like that's true isn't it
no who actually secures our nation is C
Customs and Border Patrol officers who
are putting their lives on the line
every single day you're gonna if you're
gonna disrespect your expert okay I hate
our troops mr. Ronnie thank you for
coming on today I appreciate it